♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden today signed the
bipartisan infrastructure
bill into law.
And I think it's good that
he's finally taking action
against the dilapidated
and crumbling approval rating.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
did not attend today's
signing ceremony
for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill.
But in another middle finger
to the right, Big Bird did.
Former President Trump released
a statement on Saturday
encouraging primary campaigns
against Republican House members
who voted for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill and said,
"Saving America starts
by saving the GOP
from RINOs, sellouts,
and known losers."
Take it from him,
all of those things.
In his new book,
former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie
writes that
while he was hospitalized
with the coronavirus,
former President Trump
called him to ask him,
"Are you going to say
you got it from me?"
Aww! That's actually --
That's actually sweet.
Just like the card he sent when
Melania was pregnant.
[ Ohs and applause ]
Now...
After Senator Bernie Sanders
tweeted,
"We must demand that
the extremely wealthy
pay their fair share,"
Tesla CEO Elon Musk
replied yesterday and said,
"I keep forgetting
that you're still alive."
Wow. Well, that is one
of the side effects.
Vice President Kamala Harris
has reportedly told confidants
that she feels constrained
with what she's able to do,
politically,
in the Biden administration.
"Same," said Biden.
On a new episode of his podcast,
Joe Rogan said
that he's so flexible,
he's capable of performing
oral sex on himself,
or, as he calls it,
"Doing my own research."
And, finally, Buckingham Palace
announced yesterday
that Britain's Queen Elizabeth
skipped
a Remembrance Day Ceremony
due to a sprained back muscle.
Apparently,
she heard that Rogan story
and wanted to give it a shot.
Picture it.
♪♪
President Biden signed
the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
into law yesterday and said,
"America is moving again.
And, this time, not to Canada."
[ Laughter ]
During the signing
ceremony yesterday
for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill,
President Biden twice referred
to Arizona
Senator Kyrsten Sinema
as Krysten, and that's the worst
thing you can call her,
besides a Democrat.
She hates that.
[ Ohs and laughter ]
According to a new book,
former acting Defense Secretary
Christopher Miller
purposely offered
then-President Trump
extreme military scenarios
in the final weeks
of his presidency,
to prevent him
from choosing to attack Iran.
Unfortunately, he opted
for the craziest one --
attacking the U.S.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
I guess that's about as well
as that one could've gone.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys remember
that awful day.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
[ Laughter ]
Ha ha ha ha ha."
Former Trump advisor
Steve Bannon surrendered
to federal authorities yesterday
to face charges
of contempt of Congress and,
looking at him,
I have to assume Congress is
a brand of soap?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Biden administration
has announced it's planning
to hold the annual White House
Christmas party this year,
but, for the first time
in four years,
without Frosty.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
After being treated
for the coronavirus
at Walter Reed Medical Center
last year,
former President Trump
reportedly considered
ripping off his dress shirt
when he returned
to the White House,
to reveal a Superman shirt
underneath.
But then, he remembered
Superman was
an "undocamented inmigrant."
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Definitely said
both those words wrong.
[ Laughter ]
It is "undocamented," right?
What happened was the wheels
came off on undocumented
and then, I was lost
on immigrant.
[ Laughter ]
I think I used one of the M's
in immigrant
in undocumented,
so, there's only one left there.
[ Laughter ]
Guardrails came off, bud.
You know what?
Just, in post,
move the "M."
[ Laughter ]
Audio, if you're listening,
just take the "M"
from "undocumamented"...
[ Laughter ]
...slide it into immigrant
and I think it'll be seamless.
[ Laughter ]
They'll match it to my lips,
so, I'll just say it right now
without words
and then,
you can use these lips.
[ Laughter ]
Just watch the show tonight
and see, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's see how they
cut it together.
A woman reportedly climbed
over the barrier
to Bronx Zoo's lion exhibit
last week
while carrying a bouquet
of roses,
or, as the lion saw it,
dinner, holding some garnish.
[ Laughter and awws ]
More than 500 people in Egypt
were stung over the weekend
after flooding drove thousands
of scorpions into villages.
And that's why you don't tap
on the glass
of King Tut's mummy!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally --
[ Laughter ]
Is it a good sign or a bad sign
when I can only hear
Wally laughing?
[ Laughter ]
And fi--
I think you're laughing
because nobody else was, Wally,
and I don't like that.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, keep it up, Wally.
And, finally,
the restaurant chain Applebee's
began offering so-called
Cosmic Wings yesterday,
which features chicken tossed
in Original or Flamin' Hot
Cheetos cheese sauce,
and that's not all
they're tossed in.
♪♪
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer said yesterday
that President Biden's
Build Back Better agenda
will come up for a vote
before Christmas,
which is good,
because right now,
that manger is,
like, our sturdiest building.
President Biden
visited General Motors'
so-called Factory ZERO
electric-vehicle assembly plant
today in Michigan and you
could tell he was impressed.
He kept saying,
"So it's fully electric?
No horses at all?"
Jacob Chansley,
also known as the QAnon Shaman
from the January
Capitol insurrection
has been sentenced
to 41 months in prison.
Apparently, it's hard to find
a jury of his peers
the same day there's
a Renaissance fair.
It's been announced that
the Los Angeles Staples Center
will change its name
to the Crypto.com Arena.
So look for the Lakers to be
up by 20, then back down by 40,
then up by 10,000,
then back to zero.
Montana Senator Jon Tester
joked with reporters yesterday
that he expects
Democratic efforts to pass
President Biden's
Build Back Better agenda
to screw up his holiday plans.
Well, if it makes you
feel any better,
you're a Democrat in Montana.
Your relatives probably don't
want to see you anyway.
The New Year's Eve celebration
in Times Square
will return in-person this year
for participants
who are fully vaccinated
against the coronavirus.
But if you're unvaccinated,
you'll have to settle
for going to the Super Bowl.
Officials in Florida
recently discovered
a 20-foot-long metal box
washed up on a beach.
Even weirder,
there wasn't any cocaine in it.
Well, now I've
seen everything, Florida.
Google Cloud services
experienced an outage yesterday
which caused the music
platform Spotify to crash,
costing artists a total
of over 75 cents in profits.
Costco and Kraft Heinz
issued a recall last week
for Kool-Aid drink mix
due to possible contamination
of small pieces
of metal or glass.
Okay, well, here's a suggestion.
Stop delivering it
through walls.
That's modern, right?
That's still --
That's like
a modern ad campaign?
[ Laughter ]
I'm really excited
about this one.
The sex-toy company
Dame Products
announced this week that it
has settled its lawsuit
with New York's MTA
and will be allowed to advertise
the brand on the subway,
though still no plan in place
to make the train come faster.
[ Cheering and applause ]
First down!
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, boxer --
Former professional boxer --
And, finally, former
professional boxer Mike Tyson
said in a new interview
that he takes
Sonoran Desert tone venom --
We're going to reboot and we're
going to get this right.
I'm just so excited about that
"train come faster" joke.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like I know everybody's like,
"Move on to the next joke,"
but I want to live
in the last one.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, former
professional boxer Mike Tyson
said in a new interview that he
takes Sonoran Desert toad venom
to hallucinate.
Responded the interviewer,
"I'm a lamp."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
President Biden is set tomorrow
to pardon the annual
White House turkey
and Steve Bannon's got an idea
just crazy enough to work.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After test driving
an electric Hummer pickup truck
in Michigan yesterday,
President Biden said,
"This sucker's something else."
Okay, but, don't give him one.
I mean, the last thing
anyone needs is
a 78-year-old man driving a car
that you can't hear coming.
[ Laughter ]
After Texas Senator Ted Cruz
accused Republican
Congresswoman Liz Cheney,
in a recent interview, of having
Trump Derangement Syndrome,
Cheney tweeted,
"Trump broke Ted Cruz."
Yeah, but that's like breaking
an IKEA bookshelf.
It was about to go, anyway.
[ Laughter ]
"You put books on it?!
Ohh!
You can't put books on it!"
[ Laughter ]
Fox Chairman Rupert Murdoch
reportedly told News Corp's
shareholders -- stockholders --
Excuse me.
Shareholders, stockholders --
I think it's the same.
What do you want to go with,
Baze?
-Share.
-I think stock's funnier.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Stockholders at a recent meeting
that former President Trump
"needs to move on"
from the 2021 election.
Okay, but you, first.
[ Laughter ]
Probably hurt the joke,
doing that little side trip,
but I got my Baze burn in.
[ Laughter ]
The NFL announced yesterday
that it will heighten
its coronavirus protocols amid
rising cases across the country.
Starting this weekend,
Aaron Rodgers will be forced
to attend the huddle via Zoom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York's MTA announced
yesterday that it has approved
the purchase
of 60 fully electric buses,
which cost about $1 million each
and have a top speed of
we'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
The discount department store
chain T.J.Maxx
announced yesterday
that it will increase prices
on some of its upscale brands
and you'll know they're upscale
because they're the ones not
on the floor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York Jets quarterback
Joe Flacco announced
at a press conference yesterday
that he is not vaccinated
against the coronavirus
and said that he
"has his reasons."
I mean, he's a backup
quarterback on the Jets.
I assume his reason is
that he's ready to die.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, New York Jets
quarterback Joe Flacco announced
he's not vaccinated
against the coronavirus,
but don't worry
about his teammates.
It's rare for the Jets
to catch anything.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Yeah, why not?
Why not? Yeah.
Enjoy yourselves.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, tomorrow is
National Play Monopoly Day,
which means this Saturday is
National Finish Monopoly Day.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, that was a monologue!
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]